la plupart des prévenus étaient des
roumains installés dans le sud de la
france
il parcourait des centaines de
kilomètres pour dérober du cuivre sur
des sites sncf
au total une trentaine de vols sur tout
le territoire et notamment à venarey les
laumes migennes et gevrey chambertin en
considérés comme les cerveaux de ce
réseau deux frères de 28 et 30 ans
condamné à six ans de prison des peines
pour l'exemple selon leur avocat la
justice de l'exemple n'est pas la bonne
justice
voyez donc évidemment qu'on en parle
évidemment je sais pas si la nationalité
étrangère fait justement qu'on n'en
parle plus ou non mais si oui on est
loin du trafic d'armes on est loin du
trafic de drogue on parle de vol de
cuivre
les personnes très jeunes et qui sont là
pour le coup condamné à six ans autre
particularité dans cette affaire
plusieurs chefs d'entreprise et salariés
d'une société de recyclage qui
comparaissaient pour recel
la justice leur reprochait d'avoir
acheté du cuivre volés en toute
connaissance de cause
tous ont finalement été relaxés le
russell devait rester une infraction
intentionnelle
c'est à dire qu'on devait accepter
acheter du cuivre tout en connaissant
l'origine frauduleuse du cuivre ce n'est
absolument pas le cas pour mes clients
d'où cette rolex qui me paraît
effectivement salut à bhl dans ce
dossier hors norme 16 des 21 prévenus
ont été condamnés
ils ont dix jours pour faire appel